you know what noticed today I was like
there's something a little different
about coal over there gotta go too today
yeah and we'll switch it up on you you
like to rock a goatee whenever you're
off this was for a role that I did uh in
1883 so
you want to spill any tea about 1883. no
ma'am
I tell you what sworn to secrecy oh I've
been working on a list of who Laney
could have been kissing Lloyd Colby Ryan
Jake Ethan
you're still wrong OMG
I know you're missing one guy
rip starts with an i and ends with a B
I'm just going to tell you now Ian Bowen
oh I can't wait well this is new for you
guys out there in the world I love it I
love it
part of
the biggest perk for you right now Cole
sitting here talking to you oh but
you are pouring it on thick brother give
it to me what really and truly is being
here with my family in New York and you
know just the experience of it all and
you know listen they leave me up in
Montana for six months out of the year
yeah so to come out here and really see
the people and see how much they care
about this show and just be around you
know and and the acknowledgment it's
extremely pleasure I love Montana but
I'm doing this for our family I mean the
kids think wow papa is actually cool
they're starting to think I'm pretty
cool yeah we went to the Brooklyn Nets
game and and the next game in two nights
we have four seats so I'm doing
something all right I'd say so look 14
episodes this season being broken up
into two have fans are wondering what
gifts does this mean that the end of
Yellowstone is nearing do they have
anything to fear I don't know about all
that
um Taylor and Kevin he has a ton on his
plate and and I think you know it just
worked out the way it should which is
you know we want him to make sure that
he has time to write what he needs to
write when it comes to Yellowstone so
they made that decision okay and you
would be willing to play rip for how
long
as long as Taylor continues to write
like a badass that he is
thank you
[Music]
foreign